now to another disturbing story this one
out of Colorado a man is accused of
plotting to bomb one of the oldest
synagogues in Colorado and is now in
federal custody this morning the FBI
says it ordered a planned attack on the
temple Emmanuel synagogue in Pueblo
Colorado 27 year-old Richard Holzer is
accused of domestic terrorism
investigators say Holzer called himself
a skinhead who believed he was fighting
a racial holy war jeff buguese his
outside FBI headquarters in Washington
DC Jeff good morning how did the FBI
find this guy
well good morning investigators say
Holtz are used several online Facebook
accounts to post hate-filled rants FBI
undercover agents first engage him
online in September and then in person
as he moved from talking about an attack
to actually taking steps to carry one
out mister hoelter repeatedly expressed
his hatred of Jewish people and a
support of a racial holy war US attorney
Jason Duns and Holt sir told undercover
FBI agents of his plan to attack pueblos
Colorado's temple Emmanuel synagogue
early Saturday morning mr. holes are
indicated that he wanted to do something
that would let Jewish people in the
Pueblo community know that they are not
welcome and that according to him they
should leave or they will die according
to court papers Holt's were met with the
undercover agents last Friday at a motel
he told the agents their plan for attack
was a quote move for our race the agents
gave him two pipe bombs and 14 sticks of
dynamite all were inert holt sir didn't
know that and set the attack for 2:30 or
3:00 the following morning shortly after
that he was arrested webelo police chief
troy davenport this kind of behavior is
frankly intolerable in our city his
arrest comes just over a year since a
gunman killed eleven worshippers at the
Tree of Life synagogue in Pittsburgh
according to the anti-defamation league
since that attack at least 12 white
supremacist have been arrested for
plotting to attack or threaten the
Jewish community and a total of 780
anti-semitic incidents were recorded in
the first six months of this year
the ADL says that the US continues to
experience a record high number of
anti-semitic incidents if convicted
holter faces a maximum 20 years behind
bars
Gail Jeff's thank you very much